[Musique]
Maribel a l'initiative
très communicatif après la Silicon Valley
paré problème b7 le transformateur
apa
[Musique]
presque solide
les problèmes les polémiques
lentille
Elise respecte cette initiative
Lucia, où a-t-il un yo, c'est ok si l'UE
ça coûte énormément en ville
nouvelle vague moubaraks nous alice des
initiative des ministères des grands blocs
peut écouter de la musique populaire
il était plus accepté d'être zéro en dessous
Cela correspond au résultat opérationnel
ebit niveau la colorada tarifs repos
dialogues
Riedrode premiers baisers bisous ours sont
Daniel Nestor Leonie principalement à Estoril
[Musique]
respect respecte la politique qu'y a-t-il d'autre
tu peux me parler de politique politique
Le problème d'Elias n'est qu'un autre problème
[Musique]